the german philosopher friedrich  heinrich jacoby was one of the first to  use the term nihilism in philosophical  writings towards the end of the 18th  century later on in russia nihilism  became synonymous with a revolutionary  movement that rejected the authority of  the state church and the traditional  values of the time russian anarchist  peter krotoptkin as stated in the  encyclopedia britannica defined nihilism  as the symbol of struggle against all  forms of tyranny hypocrisy and  artificiality and for individual freedom  nihilism was essentially the fundamental  value of the anarchist movement that  wanted to destroy the core aspects of  the old world in order to allow a new  one to rise